As we have mentioned earlier, configuration is a kind of design,
a kind of routine design. And one material configuration is bound refinement.
In configuration, all the components of the design are already known, but
we are to find some arrangement with the components, and
we assign values to some of the variables of those components,
to arrive at the arrangement. Here is a design specification working it's way.
Here might be a plan for designing a chair as a whole. And
once we assign values to some of the variables at the level of the chair,
then we can refine the plan for the chair into a plan for the chair legs,
the chair seat, and so on. All of this might be subject to some constraints.
There are in fact a number of AI systems, that do configuration design.
Many of them are being used in industry. Some of these AI systems use,
matters like brand refinement the way we are showing it here.
Others use case based reasoning. And various systems use a variety of methods,
for doing configuration design, including model based reasoning and rule based
reasoning. What about more creative kinds of design? Design in which not all
the parts are known in advance. Since we just discussed the flashlight example,
in the context of systems thinking, let us revisit that example in the context
of creative design. So this is a schematic of the flashlight circuit.
Here is the switch, the battery, the bulb, as earlier. On the systems thinking,
we discussed how structured behavior function models capture the knowledge that
when the switch is closed, electricity flows from the battery to the bulb, and
the bulb converts the electrical energy into light energy. Let us suppose that
this particular electrical circuit use a 1.5 volt battery and
created 10 lumens of light. Tomorrow someone comes to you and
says, I want 20 lumens of light. Design a flashlight electrical circuit for me.
How will you do that? You might go to the structure, behavior function model for
this particular circuit and do some thinking. You may recognize, the amount of
light created in the bulb is directly proportional to the voltage of
the battery. Instead of creating 10 lumens of light you need 20 lumens of light,
you might say, I'm going to use a 3 volt battery. So far, so good. You've done
system thinking in the context of design thinking. But now let us add a wrinkle.
Suppose that a 3.0 volt battery is not available. At this point,
a teacher tells you it's okay if a 3.0 volt battery is not available.
You can connect two 1.5 volt batteries in series. Two 1.5
volt batteries connected in series will give you the voltage of three volts.
Accepting the teacher's advice, you can now create an electrical circuit
that will use two 1.5 volt batteries in series and create light of 20 lumens.
But you're not just creating this particular design, you also learned something
from it. Every design, every experience is an opportunity for learning.
In the 1990s, Sam [UNKNOWN] here at Georgia Tech created a program called IDOL,
IDOL did creative design. In particular, IDOL would learn about design patterns.
>From simple design cases, the kind we just talked about.
I'm sure most of you are familiar with the notion of design pattern,
design patterns are a major construction software engineering. But design
patterns are not just in software engineering but in all kinds of design, for
example architecture and engineering and so on. There is some way of capturing
the design pattern that can be learned from the previous case. A field of design
of a device that changes the valuable variable from one value to another value.
And you want another design that changes the value the same variable to some
other value not the same as the previous design. One way you in which you can
create the new design is. By replicating the behavior of the previous design.
So not just having behavior be one for the first design, but
having this behavior be one as many times as needed. Let us connect this to
the example we just saw. If you have a design of an electrical circuit that can
create 10 lumens of light, and you know how to do it through some behavior B1.
I need to design an electrical circuit that can create 20 lumens of light, but
you don't know the behavior of B2. Then this behavior B2
is a replication of behavior B1 by connecting components and series.
Once Sam's program IDOL had learned about this design pattern of cascading,
of replication, then, when it was given the problem of
designing a water pump of higher capacity than the one available.
It could create a new water pump by connecting several water pumps in series.
Thus, ideal, created new designs in one domain, the domain of water pump,
through analogical transfer of design patterns learned under the domain,
the domain of electrical circuits. You would form the perspective of the new
domain of water pumps initially did not know about all the components about all
the water pumps that will be needed. With Sam's program, IDOL is creative enough
to know that the pattern of problems here in the water pump is exactly the same
pattern that was also occurring in the domain of electrical circuits.
Sam's theory provides a computational account of not only how design patterns
can be used, but also about how these design patterns can be learned and
transferred to new domains. There is of course a lot more to design.
We said earlier that design thinking engages problem solution,
core evolution. It's not just that a solution evolves but
the problem remains fixed. But the problem evolves even as the solution evolves.
It's not quite clear how humans do this kind of creative design,
with this problem solution co evolution. There is certainly a few AI
systems capable of problem solution coevolution at present